let's continue and we got a black game
let's play philidor
oh because knight f3 never i guess we're
not playing a filibar
so okay well let's play d5
and wow the licits in gambit that is a
very now this is a move this is called
elicits and gambit
i'll talk about who listens and was
after the game
um now we're supposed to take the spawn
and this is a good uh
let's call it this way this is a good
case study and how to react to gametes
let's say you've never seen this before
how do we respond to this
well we gotta we gotta get get a sense
of the landscape here
and we gotta understand okay what is the
knight doing well he's
threatening to take the pawn and he's
putting pressure on f7
our first priority generally is going to
be developed naturally
and the natural development move is
knight f6 he's not threatening to take
on f7
we don't need to panic d3 is a move
but the thing that you got to hold in
the back of your head is that you can
always consider giving back whatever was
sacrificed
uh give it back but gain something such
as a more
such as an easier position to play and
from a practical perspective that could
be
just so liberating rather than trying to
cling to the pawn so let's say we go d3
we start thinking we say well e takes d3
is super
uh tempting right but then he's going to
play bishop takes d3
and the d file is going to get opened
and there's i'm going to show you guys
after the game
all of the traps that uh exist in that
position
and there are many so let's say
that we wanted to play practically we
wanted to give back the pawn
and be very annoying what move could we
play here
to do that this is a bit of an
anti-climactic question
we don't need to do anything we should
just let him take the pawn
because then we're going to take his
queen and we're going to get an end game
that's annoying for him
no you don't need to play h6 see that's
an illusion
we don't need to push him into taking
the pot if he doesn't want to take the
point it doesn't have to
but allow him to take it if he wants to
so e5 is a good move to develop the
bishop but
even simpler just make a developing move
but don't don't touch him let him
let him do his thing yeah knight c6
knight c6 okay that's a very uh powerful
move psychologically too because
when your opponent plays a gambit not to
overanalyze this but put yourself in his
shoes
does your opponent want a slightly worse
endgame that is like the last thing your
opponent is going to want
so you're you're using the psychology of
gambit players against them
um and okay so he goes knight c3 so he
doesn't want to take it
but now that we've developed the knight
on c6 we could simply continue
developing
and to continue developing what move
seems very effective
yeah bishop g4 but the thing is that if
he plays f3
then we take on f3 and then the whole
point of the move d3
was that we would take the pawn and we'd
open up his bishop
and if f3e takes f3 then his bishop and
that's that's what happens
look at his bishop his bishop is
undeveloped look at his king now his
entire structure is ruined and we got to
keep our extra pawn
so using this threat of and we step back
no problem
using the threat of a annoying position
we totally set him off kilter
okay so let's take and
in this position it makes sense to play
more conservatively
i think a lot of you want to go like
here here but let's
let's build up a solid structure there's
no need
to claim more space we've already done a
lot of good work here
let's go e6 and develop even bishop e7
is good
um but on second thought
what would be a more active developing
move i'll talk about this after the game
although e5 was perfectly fine
e5 was perfectly fine but i'll mention
my reasons
yeah lovely bishop c5 stop him from
castle although i would have preferred
bishop before to be honest
but bishop c5 is good too because then
he's probably going to go here and then
try to castle
that would be my guess and that would
actually be
you know knight p5 well this guy is just
like
you know he's
really trying but
there is a good way to defend this pawn
and that is to ask ourselves
this knight has departed from c3 so it's
no longer controlling d5 not that we
couldn't have gone 95 even with this
knight here but now it's even stronger
because
it defends the spawn and well this
knight is now on my nerves
officially so get off my back please
sir please go back to c3 so we could
continue living our life
he's probably gonna go like c4 or
something he seems to be the kind of
player who likes to respond aggressively
i feel like the or like d4 okay no it
was knight c3
my profit sense is failing me today but
now
he's he's created and see this is
another thing that experience tells you
i can sense that he's weakened his
position
so much that my killer instinct is
firing
i'm sensing something there's too many
weaknesses here
and that thought leads you to the
thought of look at what aggressive moves
could i come up with here
and if you look for aggressive moves you
will find one
what does that move look like even more
aggressive than queen f6
think about specifically what weak
squares he has in his position
because he's got his pawn on f3 so this
is undefended
we can stick a knight in there but that
is a very important follow-up move to
this
and we can yeah so knight d4 is gonna be
the follow-up move
and even if the queen is here he won't
be able to take this knight because of
the fork
common concept right these two knights
positioned in this way
yeah we can still go knight t4 right and
he can't castle either side the great
thing about a knight here
is that it prevents him from castling
both ways so his king is held down in
the center
and the game is essentially over i mean
he's just overwhelmed with threats here
or overflowing with excuses
i'll talk about that screws let me take
down your question that's a great
discussion topic but
goodbye queen i think the game will end
shortly and then we'll talk about it
so on my level much less because
most of the people i play i know or i've
played them before so we know each other
well enough where
the sort of the psychological tricks
go only so far um
you choose your openings yes based on
your opponents though but you know let's
cast
to a degree but um
it's not a big deal but at this level
uh you know you really do want to get a
read on your opponent and
who your opponent seems to be but you
don't want to take that too far you
don't want to try to make moves only
because you're trying to avoid a certain
type of position
right you you haven't you got to be
careful where you take the steering
wheel
what should we do now
yeah knight c4 no i oh well knight c4
earlier was
he would just move his king but now it
wins it wins okay so he resigns
see now it makes sense because we also
win the exchange
all right
okay so this is the list it's in gambit
so
georgia listetson was an international
master from the soviet union
and he was more known as a chess coach
uh he also authored a very famous book
that's very this is like a classic
soviet chess book from 1952
and it gets the title gets straight to
the point strategy and tactics of chess
mastery
gee listen and it was basically i loved
this book so much
that like i basically bounded in this
like binding so it doesn't like because
this is the original edition from 1952
and i
basically read this whole thing so
let me look at the date markers let me
tell you guys when
i read this 2004
2004 yeah
starter does before so when i was eight
this is one of my first books actually
and it's like a couple it's like 500
pages it's like it's amazing
i still use it in my lessons and he
covers
everything but listens and also
developed this this gambit which is
which is interesting but of course very
dubious
which is of course very dubious um
but in this position after he takes d3
bishop takes d3
what white is often going for is a very
famous trap
this trap manifests itself after h6
white it's russian of course white to
play in when i i translated
the name white to play and win
and a lot of you guys know this knight
takes f7 king takes f7
we've talked about this this is a
standoff the queen is undefended the
king is weak bishop g6 wins the bit
when's the queen
but not bishop c4 c and you got to be
careful actually no bishop c4
king yeah you can do it like this but
here maybe black and worm
worm his way out with like knight t5 but
bishop g6 is
far more accurate okay but the thing is
like black can just go knight c6 here
and black is better
but what i'm trying to do is to give you
guys a road map here
for dealing with these scenarios so
knight c6 is a very powerful move
because our opponent is almost certainly
rolling his eyes
because objectively speaking he should
probably do something like this
yeah tennyson is another name for it but
does a gambit player want to play this
position whereas king
has lost his castling right so we can go
like here and then castle
and then fiance we've got a great
position this is equal from an objective
standpoint
but nobody wants to play this um if he's
playing a list that's in gambit
so that would be a good example of
harnessing the psychology smartly
we're not doing anything extreme we're
just offering back the pawn
all right um i don't know if that makes
sense
so again you don't want to take this too
far
if they're playing some crap and they're
giving up their pieces
you don't want to say well daniel said i
don't want to take the pieces that are
offered to me because gambo players like
that
well no you want to exit you want to
exercise your judgment
but if you're if you have a sense that
your opponent is some trickster and he's
playing some gamut and you've never seen
it before
always consider giving up whatever has
been sacrificed
in order to get a simplified position of
some sense
all right let me give you guys one more
example of this in the traditional black
mart dmr gamut that's d45 e4
d takes e4 now the the sort of
quote-unquote
revised move is knight c3 but the old
move is to play f3
and when this was first shown to me by
i am john donaldson thank you edward
osborne wilson
uh well that's the whole point ggc yes
yes captain obvious
black can play the move e5 which is a
great example of this you're actually
like offering back the pawn
but you're getting the same type of
annoying position for white which you
would be getting
in the licits and gambit so rather than
taking on f3
you're offering back the pawn so you
guys should see the point here
okay so knight f3 okay so let's continue
he decided to insist on it yeah andrews
thank you
but at this point the whole gambit has
lost its meaning
because the defile has remained closed
okay so gf is
of course a further mistake you should
take with a knight and limit
further damage to his position um
and people were wondering why i didn't
play five
yeah i could have no it doesn't matter
bishop h5 is perfectly fine here to keep
the pin
doesn't matter right does it make a
difference
uh and i should preface this by saying
e5
is perfectly fine in fact from a purely
well the computer prefers them both
equally okay just for your information
but why did i play e6
so to answer this question we have to
understand
why people are tempted to play fight
because you're taught to grab the center
and claim the space
but it's a question of need right do we
need to do we need
control over the center of the pawn
because when you push up on two squares
you are by definition weakening more
squares
than when you push it one square so what
i mean by this is y could go bishop g5
and look at this d5 square for example
you could you could see a scenario where
it sticks a knight in there right
when you play e6 you keep more of these
squares open for your pieces
this relates to what i said about the
the pawn storms
right you want to let your pieces do a
lot of the heavy lifting
and maybe i want to put a knight here
maybe i want to put a bishop here
and attack h2 so even though we're
getting less space
this is more solid and we're leaving the
center open for our pieces
all right i hope this makes sense and
it's not like we're not controlling the
center we're controlling some of it
but the center is gone like white is not
controlled the battle isn't taking place
over the center anymore
all right uh so i hope that makes sense
yeah well bishop g5 we can go bishop e7
no problem
i don't see the problem here and then we
can move the knight away and offer a
bishop trade if we want
or we could not we could still just go
like bishop before
we are certainly not afraid of this pin
because we could go h6
yeah so i think people are understanding
this uh but
so here i would prefer bishop b4
actually but whatever
knight b5 95 makes sense get out of
b5 and this is the crushing idea
and again this is a very common pattern
that wins a lot of games
where he can't take this knight
because well this is a royal fork right
and he can't even recapture the night
the last thing is there's a tendency for
some players to just make moves like
these because they look cool
he's like oh he can't take my knight
look at me but
the cool factor ends after king e2 and
you've got two pieces hanging and
who asked you to get into that situation
so we only played it here
because we're winning the rook not
because we're trying to be cool well i'm
always trying to be cool
but it's just who i am you know um
all right yeah
any questions uh
i can but why give up a night now you've
given up a rook for two pieces right
which is good for the two pieces
here we're only giving up one piece
because oh and this is the famous tall
quarter i
forgot to mention you guys probably know
it so tall famously said
or i'm mangling it but like the reason i
sacrificed so many pieces that you can
only take one piece
at a time this is a great great example
of that you can only take one piece at a
time
so that's the great thing about having
multiple pieces hanging
well seeing again let me not deceive you
guys the reason i see this
is because i've seen this pattern it's
not because i have some hidden sense
what i have is the pattern recognition
i've seen a gazillion games with this
exact
configuration of pieces and if i do a
quick chess-based search
and you guys give me about two seconds
i can find a million examples
sort of of this exact kind of tragedy
tragedy be falling bla black or white
in a game so here's an example that i
just whipped up
very quickly just one moment
so we are
seeing a game between daniel duverney
grand master from italy
and maladan zelich 2270
so black has just played knight d4 right
so
why can't take the knight right white
can't take the knight because
he drops the queen right you guys see
that
um and it looks like black is doing
really well like black's doing a much
better job exploiting whitespin
than vice versa but guess what white
does
he takes anyway he sacks his queen
and why does he sack his screen what is
he doing
so what's the follow-up to this let's do
it one step at a time
now if we just take on d1 that doesn't
do anything we're just down a queen for
a piece but
we got to look for intermediate moves
here and the intermediate move is of
course to play knight e6
counter attacking black's queen well
black has to move the queen where does
he move it he moves it to d7
and now you guys should be seeing the
beginning of the pattern we just
discussed
so the secondary pattern is of course
this but this is not possible
because black simply takes the knight
but
in chess you can modify things to your
advantage
bishop takes f6 g takes f6 and here it
comes knight d5
and white is winning here despite being
down a piece because
black cannot stop the barrage of threats
just like in our game even
though we are down a queen it doesn't
matter the knights are so strong when
they're occupying these squares
and okay black tries bishop e2 out of
desperation distracting the bishop
and he distracts the bishop to play king
f7
but now he plays bishop h5 check and
black resigns
beautiful move if the king goes back
this is an amazing checkmate and if he
takes on e6
what's white's idea what's white's idea
no this is my laptop because i have
chess space open and all the stream
software so it's
taking install bishop g4 and white ends
up up a piece
so i'm not sure if black had a way to
save more material but i just wanted to
show
how commonly these patterns arise okay
um so i hope this makes sense and i
didn't
i've never seen this particular game but
what i was trying to show is
the sort of abundance of these patterns
and i've probably seen another game with
this kind of thing
okay um
fork overload for sure
all right guys i got 10 gifted there
let's do one quick encore and then i'll
call it a night
yeah you get some of the same patterns
from the same openings but it's not
one-to-one correlation i mean it's not
like
every time you play an opening you get
the same stuff
um no my pc is perfectly good
but i appreciate the offer but i'm i'm
satisfied with my equipment for now
this was diverently against some guy
um the opponents were listed
all right and preliminarily thanks to
everybody for the
massive support um
for many many days now which i really
appreciate it
if you guys have been enjoying my chess
has been mediocre
lately but the community has been
phenomenal as always so thanks everybody
last game here before i call it a night
[Music]
and let's start our engines
okay let's go e4
indonesia okay and f3 oh oh no
i'm stupid i forgot to play the danish
but that's okay because
hey we um we
we gotta vary our openings anyway right
so let's play another
let's play another um opening which i
which i would recommend i would say to
people
around 1300 and above and that's a
scotch gambit
the scotch gambit starts with d4 which
is the scotch
and after e takes d4 um knight takes d4
would be the scotch
the scotch gambit is sort of a
combination between the italian and the
scotch
let's move bishop c4 here that looks
very weird to somebody who's not seen
this before it's like bishop c4
why are we not taking the pawn like what
are we gaining from that well we're
putting pressure on the f7 pawn
and the bottom line is that why did we
play
d4 we played d4 so that knight f6 could
be met with e5 and i'll give you guys
the basics afterwards you should before
check as a sharp line
the one precondition here is we have to
play very aggressively
and we have to have a good sense of
urgency when we're playing this
so bishop d2 here would be too slow we
would allow him to take
and get his night out and castle so
we gotta throw caution to the wind here
and play c3 and take with a pawn
with tempo so yes we are ruining our
pawn structure and
you know yes we're depriving our knight
of this square on the other hand we are
gaining tempo so this is a very
instructive moment
because yeah so nice bishop f7 queen d5
check is a tactic that is as old as the
hills now
shouldn't we start with queen d5 would
be a logical question to ask
why don't we win a piece by starting
with queen d5
he defends with queenie seven very good
and that's a very commonly missed idea
that he can bring the queen out the
queen is very good at doing this like
defending two things at once
just make sure that you're checking for
that when you think you have your
opponent in a fork so first we take here
we don't want a piece but we do get his
king out
and now we pick the piece back up with
queen d5 and queen takes c5
and white is better not much better but
better we've got long term
pressure against his k okay
yeah so actually that's a good idea i
mean
we can throw this check in just to make
him
either go g6 which would expose him
along this diagonal
and why would that be meaningful well
because he's going to lack
and kudos he's going to lack a dark
squared bishop
so think about where we might put what
would be a good plan here
well what would be a good fob how do we
actually exploit the
the weakness of that diagonal
well first oh this is a sexy move for
sure yeah bishop h6
i mean either bishop b2 is what i had in
mind and this plan
but now that i think about it bishop h6
looks phenomenal as well
but let's remember that he can't castle
anyway but if we wanted to be
really five fed if we wanted to be like
really restricted we would play c4 first
so he doesn't play d5 but here we're
going to go bishop b2
because it occurred to me that if he
goes d5 we could just take his pawn and
then go c4 and
attack whatever's on d5 and also his
rook
okay so
remember always that the queen shouldn't
always be on the front lines in such an
attack
i can sense that a lot of people
probably have the temptation
to keep the queen on the fifth rank
there's no
obligation to do that let's drop the
queen back to a safe spot where it's
protected by the
the personal bodyguard here remember as
hess
always likes to point out the pawn two
squares away from the knight
is guarding the two key squares that the
knight can go to
so we haven't completed well we have
many good moves here
and the queen think of the queen and i
like to sometimes compare the queen to
like a mercenary
what you want to do is you want to
reserve the queen for very
specialty tasks like yeah quickly go
after this weak pawn that's been created
um but in this case let's
let's be very patient remember he can't
castle so let's complete our development
let's not
let's not do anything crazy until until
everything is done let's get our night
out
let's castle and now we can start
thinking about concrete action
okay he's preparing to castle but he's
he's moved his king remember
okay so we need to make a plan
we need to figure out how we are going
to now start exploiting
the fact that his king is in this is in
the center well fortunately there's a
principle in such cases we want to open
up the center
right opening up the center is what
you're supposed to do when there's a
king that is permanently in the center
so opening the center is quite
straightforward here right what move
eventually do we want to play
to open the center chasing and we're not
going to play it immediately
we want to play e5 but e5 is premature
and you guys are seeing this which i
love
because if we play e5 what is he going
to do
how is he going to keep the center
closed
he's going to go
d5 and okay we haven't accomplished much
so our bishop is also inactive which is
another way to approach this
so we first play c4 we control the
square with the pawn
and e5 is going to be a whole lot
stronger now because the bishop is also
convenient and we don't even have to
play e5
and that's what i refer to as flex well
not what i refer to as but
this is the concept of flexibility when
you make
good healthy moves you often find oh
well
i played this move with this idea but
hey
now i discovered that there's all these
other ideas that just emerge naturally
so that's the great thing about playing
good healthy solid chess
okay well you need to hold like the
control button or
like the alt button they lead to
different different ones okay queen g4
if you guys don't mind let's begin by
politely asking the queen
politely but firmly asking the queen to
get out of my face
um
okay and
now we have a very five head maneuver
which has nothing to do with our initial
plan see that's exactly
now how do i see this well i mentioned
earlier that
when the queen is stuck in no man's land
it can be very susceptible to attacks
and that thought should immediately lead
you to knight g5 but what's the
follow-up here why are we attacking
where is this night actually going
this is frankfort airport we're not
staying on g5
where are we flying to in the end yeah
we're flying to f6
we're going to do that by taking on h7
and then going to f6 and that is going
to be an absolutely devastating move
whether or not it comes with check
okay and it will come with check and
it'll come with a fork
and guess what are we going to rush to
take this rook
no because this knight is so incredibly
strong as an attacker
that it might be worth not taking the
rook but rather
keeping the knight here because it is
restricting the king from coming back to
d7
in fact that's exactly what we're going
well
it is tempting to take the rook so
there's many ways to approach this
and many good ideas here but one of them
is actually to pawn storm him
right e5 he can still go d5 but there is
a very quick little yeah i like f4 now
he can trade queens here if he wants
then we we're going to take his queen
and take his rook and we're going to be
completely winning in the end game
but if he doesn't then we're going to
play f5 we are going to force the center
open
either by taking g6 or by opening up the
e file
so i hope exactly
am i i'm not regretting my words i will
not apologize
yes let's go f5 check he's probably
gonna he's
okay knight f5 has just collapsed now we
just thank you for the i mean now we
take his knight and we're
crushing him too and we're now going to
this is a double check by the way
so you know the funny thing is
there is the zen move here
do you guys want to play like a zen
match if you want to play like a zen
master
you don't take on g6 okay
amazingly there's another move so the
way that my brain works
is i see the first thing i saw when i
looked at this
is i really want to give them a check
here i
really want to give him a check here
because that would send the king right
in the path of the bishop there'd
definitely be some sort of a checkmate
there right
but that's not a great move right now
because he can take our queen right
so queens are easy to deal with we can
chase this queen but if we go rick ac1
be very careful about considering what
squares have been left behind he can go
queen takes a2
well that's too bad can we improve that
idea to
uh to disallow that yeah rook fc one and
that looks like such an awkward move
but it makes sense right i hope the
logical chain there makes sense
thank you swiftier he's gonna move the
queen we're gonna give him a check
a check and a checkmate on g6 is how i
think the game is going to end
well he's going to help us along okay
well it doesn't really matter actually
i was well i was i actually was not
wrong
that's the funny thing king g7 oh god
1290 that's not good
yeah okay
so the scotch gamut is one of those old
school openings
that is actually still good
and again the point is if black plays
knight f6 we go
e5 but those of you in the know
will know that d5 here is the main
theoretical move now i'm not gonna again
i don't have enough energy to go into
the details right now
but the bottom line here
is that after dc bc
um already black needs to be very
careful
i think bishop a5 is actually the only
legitimate
move here and this almost transposes
into an evans gambit
because if and this is a trap to
remember if he plays bishop b7
white is already winning on the spot
thank you dolphie for the prime
oak queen f6 is better that's pog maybe
i'm not up to date on the theory by the
way
because after queen d5
whoa well after queen d that is that is
the
game but on steroids he has no defense
against queen takes f's i mean he can
play knight h6
in fact he has to but now white is
simply up a piece
so i mean this will happen very often
at 14 1500 level as people will give a
check which is understandable they want
to develop a tempo
but then they'll get in very big trouble
in this position
now at this point i think i explained
everything queen h5 is very accurate
and then bishop b2 opening the diagonal
everything we did was very
straightforward we developed
we played c4 to prepare e5 but then
we exploited the newfound powers of the
bishop and the vulnerable situation of
his queen
to get our knight to f6 now rather than
sort of myopically taking the rook we
said well the knight is very strong here
let's try to squeeze more out of the
position so we played f4
and we played f5 and finally we came up
with this idea brook fc1
which forces the queen away from its
defense of e6
so it didn't matter where he went this
would have been made anyway knight h5
double check has to go here or to h6 and
queen takes g6
is checkmate and that is all she
wrote ladies and gentlemen okay
i'll see you guys later take care
everybody have a great day
stay safe and stay sane um
and i'll see you guys later all right
[Music]
bye